sí
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bienvenidos a corresponsales de france
24 turquía ha liderado los esfuerzos por
encontrar una salida diplomática al
conflicto entre rusia y ucrania de los
encuentros de alto nivel que se
celebraron recientemente en estambul
salieron nuevas propuestas como la
creación de un acuerdo multinacional que
le ofrezca garantías de seguridad de
ucrania a cambio quien ofrece renunciar
a sus aspiraciones de ingresar en la
otan en la ciudad del sur de turquía de
antalya una de las más turísticas del
país conviven en varias decenas de miles
de rusos y ucranianos antes de la
invasión ambas comunidades compartían
espacio familia y amistades pero ahora
los recelos y la atención han separado a
estas personas nuestro corresponsal en
turquía adrià rocha nos acerca a sus
historias
hoy es un día intenso
estas cajas llenas de ayuda irán hacia
harkov ucrania
violen a una joven ucraniana ha venido a
ayudar
elena vive en antalya en el sur de
turquía donde rusos y ucranianos hacen
vida como vecinos sin embargo la guerra
ha hecho que muchos rompan relaciones en
esta ciudad
obviamente cuando algunas personas
se estima que en antalya habitan 28 mil
rusos y cerca de 10 mil ucranianos
holgado de nacionalidad rusa quien aún
mantiene contacto con sus amigas
ucranianas lamenta lo que su gobierno le
está haciendo a ucrania
no me da vergüenza ser rusa es mi país
mi gente
pero si me avergüenza el presidente de
mi gobierno y si siento miedo por mi
futuro
y
desde que comenzó la invasión olena sale
poco de casa por el miedo y el estrés
sin embargo ha decidido visitar a su
amiga nastase a quien trabaja con siendo
vestidos y banderas día y noche
para poder enviar dinero a su familia en
ucrania ella es el único sustento
económico que les queda
para mí lo más importante es que mi
familia aún está viva pero por supuesto
que cada vez que voy a dormir pienso que
les puede ocurrir algo es muy difícil me
afecta mucho emocionalmente y
físicamente no es fácil estando tan
lejos sin poder hacer nada es verdad
anastasia como muchos otros ucranianos
tiene familia en rusia pese a ello
perdonar y sanar las heridas que provoca
esta guerra dice le costará muchos años
con miras a fomentar un buen avance de
los diálogos el ministerio de defensa de
rusia anunció que reducirá
dramáticamente su actividad militar en
cercanías de kiev la capital ucraniana
esto cuando la guerra ya ha entrado en
su segundo mes un conflicto que deja
miles de muertos y más de 10 millones de
desplazados según naciones unidas
nuestras enviadas especiales irene sabio
y leticia álvarez nos muestran
testimonios que recuerdan esas obras
posteriores al inicio de la invasión
rusa
[Música]
el 24 de febrero el mundo se paralizó
para millones de ucranianos tras meses
esperando una invasión rusa la guerra
había empezado
el catering aus a nova es una joven
informática que vio su vida quebrarse de
madrugada
cuando leí de las bombas al principio me
sentí frustrada frustration
no sabía qué hacer y pensé que no podía
irme a ninguna parte porque no tenía
sitio alguno al que ir al fatah hernán
puesto que toda su vida estaba en kiev
sus hobbies amigos y planes de futuro
todas las copias son 11 años de mi vida
pero tengo un hobby que es grabar vídeos
esto es algo que no podía dejar atrás
no es la primera vez que caterina tiene
que huir en 2014 escapó de crimea desde
entonces convive con el miedo
tengo la sensación de que no importa
donde vaya rusia vendrá otra vez y
tendré que irme otra vez no siento que
exista un lugar seguro en ninguna parte
en ganar la historia se repite con
dimitros beats una alerta en el teléfono
y las llamadas de familiares en shock
alertaron a este joven abogado del ibi
protesta para chaves me desperté a las 6
y en mi teléfono que la guerra había
empezado no me lo creía pero recibí
muchos mensajes de amigos y familiares y
vi los ataques en kiev zhytomyr
equipando franquicias
esta parte intenté entenderlo pero no
podía y
esa noche durmió en su despacho porque
su apartamento está cerca del aeropuerto
las sirenas antiaéreas siguen retumbando
en cada recoveco de este país el drama
humanitario se suma a la destrucción que
provocan las bombas y la artillería
vidas congeladas y martirizadas por una
guerra
con ucrania en guerra centenares de
civiles ucranianos decidieron no
quedarse con los brazos cruzados y
ayudar a sus vecinos menos afortunados
solos recorren miles de kilómetros
esquivando las balas y las bombas para
ayudar a llevar medicinas o ropa o
ayudar a abandonar los frentes de
batalla en el este del país leticia
álvarez e irene sabio enviadas
especiales de france 24 les preguntaron
por qué lo hace
el corazón de badín se acelera cuando el
sonido de la artillería suena cerca va
esquivando el peligro para poder
transportar ayuda humanitaria del ibi
fajar kif dos días de trayecto
recorriendo ucrania de oeste a este
da miedo muchas veces estamos muy
nerviosos sobre todo cuando pasamos por
los checkpoints o cuando estás cerca de
los ataques con artillería o caen los
misiles
da mucho miedo cuando estás en un atasco
y escuchas el sonido de los ataques esto
no es una posible transporta en tiendas
de campaña y medicinas también evacuan a
vecinos que escapan a la desesperada de
los bombardeos continuados del ejército
ruso en kharkiv una de las ciudades más
martirizados por la invasión rusa
hacemos esto porque estamos unidos por
una idea unidos por el dolor
porque yo personalmente no puedo
quedarme sin hacer nada
y ahora ya no puedo esperar quieto sin
hacer nada viendo lo que está pasando en
mi propia ciudad y entendí que muchos de
mis amigos estaban allí con muchas
familias que nos interesemos dmitro era
baterista de un grupo antes de sortear
fragmentos de metralla para ayudar a sus
vecinos en su teléfono guarda las
imágenes que se van encontrando en el
camino el humo y la destrucción de mi
trono audio decidió viajar para ayudar
la primera vez fueron mis amigos los
amigos de mis amigos y después fue mi
familia
no querían irse de casa porque era duro
para ellos 'tengo for home
la guerra mató a su abuela ya su padre
pero dmitro a penas reflexiona sobre
ello tan sólo piensa en sobrevivir y en
ayudar a los que aún no han muerto lo
mismo hace badín su vida solo eso le
permite en tiempos de guerra
[Música]
el sur de ucrania ha sido la zona más
golpeada por la guerra principalmente en
la ciudad de mariupol que ha quedado
totalmente destrozada por los bombardeos
y cuya situación ha sido catalogada por
las autoridades como catastrófica
organismos como la cruz roja sigue
abogando por que las partes logran un
acuerdo que permita la evacuación de
civiles por otra parte es el principal
puerto ucraniano sobre el mar negro se
ha mantenido preparada ante la
posibilidad de un ataque allí la mayoría
de la población habla ruso y su relación
con rusia data de hasta tiempos de su
fundación en 1742 por orden de la
emperatriz catalina la grande a pesar de
los lazos familiares comerciales e
históricos muchos piensan que pase lo
que pase la relación con rusia nunca
podrá volver a hacer la misma informe de
catalina gómez ángel y oriol andrés
gallardo
la catedral norte de chad o de esa
estaba siendo de costumbre la invasión
rusa ha llevado a que muchos más
feligreses la visiten para pedir por el
fin de la guerra y la protección de su
ciudad
y toda la comunidad religiosa de deza
esta unidad actualmente con una misma
idea y acciones para proteger el país
el dolor del arzobispo y de negociar es
visible la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana se
ha visto atrapada en esta guerra condenó
la invasión rusa desde el primer día y
pidió al patriarca a la iglesia de moscú
para que intercediera ante vladimir
putin sus acciones no han tenido éxito
en absoluto la agresión nos duele el
doble pues viene de un pueblo con el que
compartimos la misma célula del millón
de habitantes yo de esa más del 80% son
ortodoxos el idioma mayoritario es el
ruso y miles de familias están
repartidas a ambos lados de la frontera
ese es el caso de este grupo de amigos
que discuten sobre la invasión
tengo nacionalidad ucraniana pero nací y
crecí en una comunidad de ruso parlante
nunca me cabe en la cabeza que esto esté
pasando
en la
nación ucrania cuando era parte de la
unión soviética pero para víctor la
relación es aún más estrecha nació en
rusia donde vive gran parte de su
familia nueva ya que usted ve en mi cara
la de un hombre que ha sido reprimido
porque habla ruso esto es absurdo y muy
grande en estas calles pocos olvidan que
una de las justificaciones de putin para
invadir ucrania era la defensa de los
resonantes y
aquí todos hablando ruso usted puede
chequear en la iglesia solo dos misas en
ucranianos uno más o ni reina o de esa
es una ciudad cosmopolita acoge más de
120 nacionalidades y decenas de
confesiones que se han unido para dar
apoyo a quienes resisten en la ciudad
como en esta iglesia católica
porque si aún no tenemos por ser minoría
sino por la guerra que es terrible para
la pena
en estos cultos saben bien que una
victoria rusa significará la pérdida de
la libertad una pesadilla que nadie
quiere enfrentar
la invasión de ucrania orquestada por
vladimir putin ha desatado una oleada de
solidaridad desde españa toneladas de
ayuda organizadas y distribuidas gracias
a cientos de voluntarios que han dejado
de lado su vida laboral y personal para
desempeñar esta gigante labor logística
y humanitaria porque cada furgoneta que
llega a la frontera entre polonia y
ucrania con comida o con material
sanitario vuelve a españa repleta de
refugiados ucranianos que huyen de la
guerra nos lo cuenta nuestra
corresponsal en madrid marina colorada
y aunque vive a miles de kilómetros de
su natal ucrania la vida de natasha
también cambió de golpe el 24 de febrero
ponemos cajas de medicina rosa lo que
era una empresa de venta de productos de
belleza y demostraciones de cocina se ha
convertido en un centro de acopio de
ayuda para los afectados por la guerra
este es una cocina o sea todo esto ahora
mismo es son medicamentos que luego
nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es comprar
las neveras para poder mandar no también
en frío y que llegue bien en hasta
ucrania y en nuestras manos en lo que
tenemos algo ahora mismo pues eso es lo
que tenemos que hacer es ayudar y si hoy
por ejemplo no hago una limpieza facial
y no cobro dinero
o sea ellos tienen menos ellos han
quedado sin casas
uno de los muchos voluntarios que
reciben y organizan lo que va llegando
es nahuel la pareja de natasha un
argentino residente en madrid dueño de
una inmobiliaria que acaba de volver de
polonia de traer a varios refugiados
ucranianos nosotros al final nos fuimos
de nuestro país por decisión propia y
todo hemos perdido esencia cuando te vas
de tu país y ver que eso es al final se
lo arrebata ni una decisión imaginamos
que el nuestro dolor todavía es mucho
más grande el derecho perfecto esta
semana es jose el que emprende la misma
travesía que hizo nahuel este texto con
donde recoges a la gente si seis mujeres
y niños volverán con este maestro de
pedagogía que deja de lado su trabajo y
a su familia durante unos días es una
suerte poder hacerlo yo voy muy contento
de poder hacerlo
un esfuerzo el máximo esfuerzo ha sido
que tengo un niña de 3 años alonso que
lo voy a dejar de ver durante una semana
pero creo que cuando él sea mayor lo
entenderá mientras jose recorre
kilómetros la actividad en el local de
natasha no cesa comienza una nueva
operación logística para enviar más
ayuda a ucrania
queremos agradecer a la cinemateca de
bogotá por permitirnos grabar nuestro
programa en sus instalaciones y a
ustedes muchas gracias por seguir una
nueva emisión de corresponsales siga con
más información en france 24 y france 24
puntocom